[Musique]
je m'appelle jean philippe salle 1 j'ai
32 ans et je suis médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur la semaine dernière en fin
de vacation je dois endormir un enfant
pour une irm sous anesthésie générale
il est déjà traité depuis plusieurs mois
pour une tumeur cérébrale récidivante la
situation est sous contrôle
la procédure est simple et ne nécessite
pas de gestes techniques
lorsque je rejoins mon dernier patient
je ne vois pas timéo quatre ans et caché
en boule sous ses draps ses parents me
regarde fatigue et résignés des
infirmières ont tout essayé mais rien
n'y fait il refuse de sortir sa tête il
dit qu'il joue je sais qu'il ne joue pas
pour l'endormir il faudra le perfuser
nécessairement la situation semble sans
issue et l'hypothèse d'un report devient
de plus en plus probable c'est à l'ours
est alors que je m'agenouille
spontanément et que je m'adresse à lui à
travers le petit espace qui l'avait
laissée pour nous observer timéo
je sais que tu en as marre de tous ces
examens
je sais que c'est difficile je sais que
c'est pas juste moi aussi je trouve que
ce n'est pas juste
mais tu sais pour faire 7 et irm il
faudra faire tous les deux un bout de
chemin ensemble
moi je peux t'en dormir mais si tu ne me
donnes pas ta main je n'y arriverai pas
ce que nous dit cette histoire c'est que
pour gagner la main la confiance de cet
enfant il aura fallu s'extraire quelques
secondes de l'immédiateté de l'action
alors que la situation semblait bloquée
je suis conduit à initier une discussion
très mature entre deux personnes un
adulte et un enfant devenu trop vite
adultes ce qui à dénouer cette situation
c'est notre capacité à reconsidérer la
juste manière la façon d'aborder de
parler à cet enfant en tenant compte de
son histoire
on est tous le fruit de son histoire
comprendre l'histoire de l'autre c'est
probablement cela l'empathie elle est en
chacun de nous il faut la mettre au
service d'une cause
pour moi c'est celle des enfants c'est
cela qui nourrit mon exercice de
médecins anesthésistes réanimateurs en
pédiatrie
je n'ai pas grandi avec lui d'exprimer
de saint geours à vrai dire j'ai
commencé par une classe prépa hec après
le bac pour rapidement choisir de me
réorienter médecine ce n'était donc pas
une vocation des premières années m'ont
paru bien longue des clics plus tard mon
sixième année on était une poignée
d'étudiants avoir pu intégrer les gardes
du samu
j'en garde des souvenirs marquants
structurant pour la suite de ma jeune
carrière notamment cette fois nous
étions sortis sur ce que l'on appelle
une hémorragie du post partum c'est une
hémorragie d'origine utérine qui
survient dans les suites d'un
accouchement je revois encore
l'anesthésiste que j'accompagnais il
technique est la patiente pour la
transfusé massivement et il effectué
l'ensemble de ses gestes dans le calme
avait eu avec une extrême précision
alors que par tout autour on pouvait
ressentir la tension qui s'était emparée
des équipes de cette histoire j'ai tiré
deux enseignements majeurs le premier
plus personnel toutes ces connaissances
qui n'était jusque là que des centaines
de pages amassés dans les livres prenez
vie toutes ces notions
lorsqu'elle était mise en pratique
devenez concrètes dès lors j'ai vécu mes
études différemment je savais que je
voulais devenir anesthésistes
réanimateurs les connaissances pouvait
sauver de ce conte actionnement il
suivant et il peut parler à chacun nous
probablement que pour s'extraire d'une
situation très aiguë très difficile il
faut être capable de prendre du recul
par rapport à l'immédiateté du moment
l'action man si elle est fugace doit
toujours être sous tendu par une vision
plus globale
un raisonnement prospectifs un
raisonnement qui s'inscrit dans le long
terme et cette vision globale loin de
desservir l'efficience de la lui donne
de la perspective lui donne du sens
on ne naît pas avec des capacités
supérieures à être confrontés
régulièrement à des situations violentes
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'enfants et si
calmes anesthésistes réanimateurs j'y
parviens ce n'est pas que soient dotés
de capacités surhumaines loin de là mais
parce que mon exercice d'un esthétisme
animateurs s'inscrit dans le spectre
d'une temporalité plus longue
une quête
deux sens dédié à servir une cause ici
celle des enfants
c'est cela qui me donne la ressources
mentales et physiques pour exercer ce
métier exigeant ces dernières années
j'étais amené à rencontrer des personnes
exceptionnelles
j'ai la chance de travailler dans une
équipe de recherche
c'est comme nous les chercheurs porte
des blouses blanches
nos métiers sont différents de prime
abord ils sont en effet le premier
maillon de la chaîne de soins travail
sur les mécanismes qui permettent de
comprendre les pathologies des
traitements pour demain mieux soigner et
pour reprendre l'exemple de cette femme
enceinte leur contribution à sa prise en
charge n'a pas eu lieu le jour du
saignement vous le comprenez mais
quelques années en arrière lorsqu'il a
fallu concevoir les traitements qui ce
jour là ont permis de la sauver
au laboratoire l'accumulation des
résultats fruit de multiples expériences
menées pendant des jours des semaines
parfois pour repartir de zéro fait sens
leur travail s'inscrit dans le temps
long il est porté par la conviction
qu'il servira l'autre vous l'avez
compris cette volonté de servir l'autre
à travers nos actions est l'une de nos
principales ressources
peu importe comme on l'appelle amour
passion aux billes conviction elle nous
donne la force de nous dépasser de
repousser nos limites
finalement c'est pas tant la nature de
l'action en elle-même que son sens qui
lui donne toute sa valeur
dans mon cas c'est cette volonté de
servir les enfants malades
mais cela peut revêtir différents
visages
aujourd'hui encore des milliers de
soignants mettre leur vie de côté entre
parenthèses pour servir sans
contrepartie les autres sur le front du
coc vide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]